also breaking tonight Amazon founder
Jeff Bezos is accusing national acquires
publisher of blackmail and extortion for
political reasons in a blog post that he
wrote late this afternoon
he claims Bezos does that a lawyer for
the National Enquirer emailed his
counsel with a threat to post sexual
pictures he had sent to his girlfriend
Lauren Sanchez and in the post Bezos
Post letters from Emma the publisher of
National Enquirer with what he calls
details of their extortion proposal and
it's very graphic Molly this is he's
getting ahead of whatever this is but
it's going to be a big big story well
and as we have learned time and time
again in recent years it is better to
not live your life in such a way that
you can be open to extortion and we're
seeing a lot of powerful men who are
having to deal with these things I will
be interesting to see what ami espanha
seems like the kind of journalism that
they're more comfortable with than some
other some more mainstream outlets are
fascinating though Lauren this story
actually I did not think got as much
coverage as it might have you have this
battle between President Trump and the
Washington Post he often points out
calls it the Amazon post things like
that its owner Jeff Bezos and then you
had the situation where the National
Enquirer did this enormous an ally of
the president in the past did this
enormous hit job on on Jeff Bezos which
really stood up quite well in terms of
the evidence that it presented I'm not
surprised that there is a follow up now